einfach kameraden aus was ich
interessant und zu auch als bundesrätin
eveline widmer schlumpf liebäugelt mit
italienisch vokabeln doch noch fehlt der
ex magistraten die zeit die ist nämlich
unter anderem die neue
stiftungsratspräsidentin von pro
senectute schweiz
unser reporter jens ist mit 32 jahren
weit entfernt vom genius aber ziemlich
nah an eveline widmer schlumpf
aufgewachsen in feldberg und so schlimm
dass sie nun die beiden von du zu durch
die gemeinsame heimat um ein bisschen
übers älterwerden dusy nieren felsberg
die erste
[Musik]
so wirklich viel anders als vorher
moderne version
[Musik]
wenn hessens erste mal selber alt
gefühlt mit riesigen und als tony alamo
erfahren
wir haben 50 mal gar nicht
[Musik]
in der öffentlichkeit diskutiert werde
wenn es ums thema auto gott das tage wo
zu groß ist es man nehme nichts wäre 2
gefallen ist mit weniger in den eigenen
vier wänden möglich als rede kann und
auch in residence liebe könnte bedeuten
dass du dir eigentlich wünsche ist dass
ihr das nicht passiert das ist deine
mama passiert ist einfach die lange zeit
im pflegeheim und uns vor allem darum
die mit weiß ob die gelassenheit
aufnehmen
[Musik]
warum der ruhige engagiert engagiert
wurde
das ist richtig
[Musik]
okay ist der kaffee standort stick
erhältlich ist wie sie beide töchter und
fühlt und den ebenfalls das diskutierten
tennis entschieden dass mein fuß machen
wo jedes in honig gemeinschaftsflächen
minute aus idealer monitoren kann kannst
für sich nehmen das funktioniert nehmen
sie kontakt auf dort gepflegt aber nie
geschossen
das markieren denn glaub ich investiere
und form ist zukunft
[Musik]
mit